ناصر الحسيني في وسكنسن ما الذي يحرك
القضايا الداخليه التي تحرك الناخب في في
وسكانسن في هذه الانتخابات النصفيه
[موسيقى]
ولايه في الغرب الاوسط الامريكي غربي
شيكاغو وغربيه
بسته ملايين من السكان
ببدعي الصناعات لكن منطقه زراعيه وبالتالي
مزارعون لهم صوت هام مدينتين فقط على
مستوى الكبر
المساحه والاهميه هي ماده العاصمه ومن
الواقع حيث نوجه الان هذه الولايه تتميز
بهواها الجمهور التاريخيه صحيح فاز بها
رئيس ايضا في الانتخابات الاخيره امام
ترامب ولكن بفارق بسيط معروفه تاريخيا هذه
الولايه بالفقيه دائما في الفوز او الفشل
بين المرشحين من اعلى المناصب الى اسفلتها
وبالتالي تظل وفيه على ما يبدو هذه
الولايه للسلوكها السياسي صحه للتعبير اهم
القضايا بنسبه 70% حسب استطاعات محليه
مؤكده بنسبه 70% هي القضايا المعيشه يعني
نتحدث عن ثمن الخبز
ده والبيض والاجار والسيارات اي تضخم
الاسعار الذي يعاني من سكان هذه الولايه
عام الهام في عمليه تصويت اليوم التي تتم
ورائي وسيتم الاغلاق بعد ثلاث ساعات من
الان العامل الثاني كارقام قضيه الاجهاض
الى حد ما السياسيون ربما لم يتوقعوا ان
الاجهاض سيكون عاملا اساسيا سيدفع بالمزيد
نحو التصويت ولايه بس كانسل كما قال
المسؤولون المحليون شهدت اعلى نسبه تسجيل
للتصويت على ماده التاريخ الان يبلغ عدد
مصاوتين في النصفي انتخابات النصفي لحالها
ثلاثه ملايين الذين يصوتون في حوالي 30
مقاطعه انتخابيه قضيه اجهاض وتداعيات على
مستوى الاجتماعي والسياسي تدفع الناخب في
ولايه بوس قاسم الى القدوم الى هذه
المراكز الانتخابيه اليوم شخصيا لاحظنا
عددا جلال كم من هائلا من النساء ترى الان
السيدات هنا يحتلنا اه
حيزا هاما في عمليه التصويت ثم ايضا
الشباب ايضا لاحظنا انهم فخرون بالمشاركه
بالتصويت التوليع عبروا عن موقفهم ثم
القضيه الثانيه التي تحرك الناخب على
الاقل في ولايه بيسانسون هي همم 56% هذا
اربطه مع ما يقوله اليوم الرئيس
الديمقراطيه في امريكا وعمليه انتخابيه
عمل التصويت يبدو ان الشكوك التي زرعت في
ذهن الامريكيين وراي العام الامريكي منذ
التجربه ترامب في وصراعاته السياسيه كما
تعلم تركت اثارها على ابن اخي الامريكي
56% من الناخبين ورائي يدفعهم هذا العامل
للقدوم الى هذا المركز والتصويت وكما تراه
ولا احد معي تدفق والسيد المستمر لهؤلاء
ولاحظ معي كميه وعدد النساء ولو في هذه
اللحظه دقيقتين او ثلاثه ثم اخر قضيه ربما
نتحدث عنها ايضا تدفع هؤلاء شباب رجال
النساء قدوم والتصويت والتعبير عن الراي
قضيه الجريمه منذ القاضي تتذكر جلال غابت
الشرطه عن لنقل الشوارع في الولايات
المتحده واشعار المجرمون بشكل عام انه
بامكانهم التحرك بسرعه
واستهداف الناس في الشوارع العامه الاخرى
اكبر مدن امريكا نيويورك كلها الان تعاني
من عنف حقيقي استهداف الاشخاص اعتداءات
لان المرشح الديمقراطيس يعرف عنه
اشارته السابقه الى دعمه لالغاء تمويل
الشرطه على خلفيه ما حصل جورج
مع هذه القضيه وانت تقول بان جريمه منتشره
[موسيقى]
التفاعل هائل يجب ان اقوله هنا ان حمله
السناتر رنج جونسون الذي يمثل الولايه وهو
جمهوري ويتقدم بنقطتين ركز في حمله بالضبط
وانتقد بارز مانديلا حول هذه النقطه
بالذات الجمهوريون ويمثلهم اذا سنتر في
هذه الحمله يقولون ويتهمون بانز بانه
لا يكرس مؤسسه الامن لا يعترف بالشرعه
بالشرعيه الحاجه الا قوه الشرطه قويه
ومتطوره ومموله بشيء بشكل جيد ويتم ربطه
في هذه الحمله القاسيه هنا
حمله قاسيه بالفعل على مستوى اللغه
المستخدمه التوهما بارز الديمقراطي الذي
يسعى الان للحصول على منصب السيناتور
الولايهما بانه مرتبط بجماعه كمال لدينا
مانجا بجماعه بلاك لايف امريكا الان بلاك
لايكس ما ترك حركه حقوقيه من الشارع
المطالبه حقوق الانسان الى اخر والمساواه
ويواجهها ماكا يجعلوا امريكا عظيمه
لجمهوريين وهذا المصطلحين الان نراهما على
هذه الحمله الانتخابي جبارز الديمقراطي
اتهموه الجمهوريه الذي يتفوق بنقطتين بانه
مرتبط ببلاك لايف ماتر بانه مرتبط بهذه
الفلسفه الجديده في الولايات المتحده
والتي تريد ان تسحب التمويل الحقيقي
والقوي والمستمر المالي لرجال الشرطه كي
يقوموا بدورهم هذا بتوع الحال وجد اذان
صاغيه لدى سكان واهالي وسكاسل وكثيرون
صدقوا بالفعل انبارز من التقدمين ويريد
القضاء على رجال الشرطه ولكن نحن خائفون
في الشوارع نريد الشرطه نريدها قويه
متطوره ومموله بشكل جيد هذه النقطه بالذات
كثيرا ببارد هنا واعطت للمرشح همم جاسم
الشيوخ بعضا من التقدم الارقام الان 50%
بوري الذي يشغل منصب حاليا في واشنطن في
كسندر وبارز 48% لم يتمكن خلال ثلاثه ايام
الماضيه من تحريك رقم 48% لدينا استطلاعات
تعطي رونج جونسون جمهوري فارق بخمس نقاط
ليس لقطتين فقط وبالتالي ننتظر بعد الوقت
بعد ثلاث ساعات كي تغلقه هنا المراكز وحول
منتصف واشنطن بتوقيت واشنطن ستكون لك اولى
النتائج واولى الارقم هل